die sim karte wird abgeschafft tänzer
quark entdeckt und bilder vom pluto
erreichen endlich die erde das sind nur
drei der fünf dem heute in den krieg zum
topf news nachdem 913 petra
elektronenvolt starkem energie rekord
sorgt das cern in genf erneut für
schlagzeilen
sie haben ein neues teilchen entdeckt
das pentagon das besteht wie der name
schon sagt aus fünf teilchen einem
antiquar und vier quarks bereits vor 46
jahren rechneten experten mit der
entdeckung dieses teilchens uns jetzt
ist es passiert und es letztes jahr
konnte das traktat nachgewiesen werden
für laien klingt der hund vielleicht
etwas unspektakulär aber es ist ein
großes rätsel für die experten
zitat die jüngste beobachtung ermöglicht
neue einblicke in die starken
wechselwirkung und bindung der quarks in
teilchen wie protonen und neutronen
davon verstehen wir bislang noch zu
wenig das sagt professor ulrich hofer
von der universität heidelberg und
sprecher der deutschen gruppen am fcb
das kernforschungszentrum cern in genf
betreibt derzeit mehrere projekte an
ihrem teilchenbeschleuniger lhc und das
lfgb wo die messung gemacht worden ist
eben eins der vielen projekte
dieser erfolg war wie der vor wenigen
wochen erzielt der energie rekord erst
nur theoretisch möglich und dass diese
theorie jetzt in praktische realität
umgesetzt werden konnte ist ein weiterer
großer schritt in der teilchenphysik
forscher berichteten inside pfiffig
reports online magazin von einer
zahnbehandlung von hits kommt 14.000
jahren
der gorilla und stefano bensi von der
universität in bologna und makula vom
senckenberg forschungsinstitut in
frankfurt am main und viele weitere
wissenschaftler kamen zu erstaunlichen
ergebnissen bei untersuchung eines
14.000 jahre alten mannes bzw seiner
reste in einem der forscher ein
gewaltiges loch in einem weisheitszahn
auf heute
sich wahrscheinlich jeder einen termin
beim zahnarzt geben lassen aber damals
überlebte nur der der hartnäckig ist
schliff musste im gebiss bewiesen
eindeutig dass der mann trotz eines
solchen meist recht schmerzhaften
schadens auch weiterhin sein essen
gekauft haben muss so ottmar kullmer der
mann erzählt eine wenn auch nicht
perfekte zahnbehandlung sie konnten
anhand von spuren im inneren des loches
herausfinden dass jemand mit hilfe eines
feuersteins das loch von karies befreit
haben muss diese art zähne zu behandeln
kann nicht mit der heutigen technik
verglichen werden aber da war das
mitunter der erste schritt zur
zahnmedizin die iss besatzung musste in
letzter zeit immer häufiger kompromisse
eingehen entweder explodierten die
versorgungs frachter wenige sekunden
nach dem start oder sie verirrten sich
wieder komplett im all und stürzen dann
wieder zu erde einige zeit kamen also
kein nachschub für die männer und frauen
der internationalen raumstation an und
dann wurden sie wie die nasa berichtete
fass von teilen eines alten russischen
wetter satelliten getroffen
am donnerstag geschah das szenario an
bord befanden und befinden sich noch
immer
scott kelly michael kornijenko und
gennady padalka alle drei mussten sich
rasch auf den weg in die sojus kapsel
machen die gefährlich nahe kommenden
teile kollidierten jedoch dann zum glück
nicht mit der raumstation die besatzung
konnte nach dem crash signal schnell
ihre arbeit fortsetzen keiner ist zu
schaden gekommen die besatzung noch die
station also all clear weltraum verkehrt
jede menge schrott diese reste von
satelliten und raketen oder
gesteinsbrocken die raumstation iss ist
ein wahrhaftiger koloss und bietet daher
diesen unkontrollierten reisenden eine
große angriffsfläche
trotz der weiten des alls auch wenn dies
so eine gewaltige oberfläche hat können
sie mit einem geschickt manöver solchen
gefährdungen ausweichen dass die ganze
besatzung in die sauce flüchten muss
kommt äußerst selten vor
bisher geschah das erst insgesamt
viermal
wir berichteten bereits am dienstagabend
bei pixum facts and fiction auf unserer
facebook-seite top aktuell von einem
neuen meilenstein der weltraumforschung
von neun jahren machte sicher die
weltraumsonde mio reisens auf den weg
ins all
und seit ein paar tagen macht die
mission der sonde schlagzeilen grund
dafür war dass new horizons einem der
äußersten planeten in unserem
sonnensystem begegnete
dienstagnachmittag war es soweit die
sonde kam den zwergplaneten pluto so nah
dass sie völlig neue aufnahmen machen
konnte sie fotografierte die oberfläche
und wertete seine atmosphäre aus über
pluto wissen die wissenschaftler derzeit
nicht besonders viel
mit den neuen daten über pluto und
dessen atmosphäre erhoffen sich die
forscher folgendes sie wollen wissen in
welcher konstitution welchem zustand
unser sonnensystem vor mehr als
viereinhalb milliarden jahren war die
ersten bilder zeigen gewaltige berge auf
der oberfläche in der nächsten zeit
erwarten sie immer mehr informationen
von der sonde gegen 21 uhr deutscher
zeit erreichten die ersten aufnahmen die
bodenstation in laurel maryland und seit
2006 legte die kleine sonde mehrere
milliarden kilometer zurück insgesamt
fünf milliarden aber beendet ist die
reise immer noch nicht new horizons soll
sich jetzt auf den weg zum rand unseres
sonnensystems machen
auf dem in sogenannten kupfergürtel da
lauern immer noch oder ruhen oder warten
noch immer 50.000 potenzielle gestirne
darauf entdeckt zu werden und vielleicht
findet sich ja sogar noch der ein oder
andere planet dort bisher war der gürtel
viel zu weit weg um überhaupt dort
genauer hinein sehen zu können wir sind
sehr gespannt
die sim karte wird abgeschafft in den
letzten jahren änderte sich die form
beziehungsweise die größe der sim karten
immer wieder von sinn über micro sim bis
zur nano sim-karte samsung und apple
wollen den wechsel ein ende machen und
den providerwechsel vereinfachen und
beschleunigen
der financial times zufolge versuchen
apple und samsung die mobilfunkbetreiber
vereinigung gsm zu überzeugen dass ein
umstieg auf diesem die embedded sim
durchgeführt wird die esim ist im
gegensatz zu herkömmlichen sim karte in
all ihren variationen keine hardware
sondern in software beim kauf eines
smartphones mit easy befindet sich diese
schon fest installiert im telefon
vorteil da sie einer software kann sich
schnell umprogrammiert werden
dadurch wird ein schneller wechsel
zwischen providern ermöglicht schon
nächstes jahr sollen die ersten geräte
auf den markt kommen wer sich im jahr
2018 ein auto in der eu kauft muss sogar
eine sim-karte darin haben warum ab 2018
muss jedes auto in der eu mit einem
sogenannten ecall system an bord
verkauft werden ein notrufsystem das
eben auf der in diesem beruf wie die
sim-karten der zukunft aussehen könnten
ja das können wir uns jetzt etwas
genauer vorstellen doch wie sehen die
smartphones der zukunft aus mehr dazu
erfahrt ihr hier oben im video
die smartphones der zukunft zu rap und
zum blog geht es hier unten und schreibt
uns doch mal in die kommentare wie euch
die entwicklung der sim-karte gefällt
also soll es einen sinn geben oder
wollte er doch lieber das kleine plastik
stückchen ins handy schieben diskutiert
es in den kommentaren
übrigens allerdings gibt es auch
natürlich unten in der video
beschreibung und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran